woke culture has gotten so out of
control on university campuses that now
even professors who themselves are
statistically speaking unlikely to be
conservative are being targeted by
students for failing to be politically
correct enough breit chang was a
professor of composition at the
university of michigan school of music
theater and dance and he had been with
the university for over 26 years that is
until he dared to offend the
sensibilities of one freshman class
shang showed his class the 1965 film
othello starring laurence olivier as the
lead now that film othello did receive
eight different oscar nominations at the
time that it was released so i'm sure
that most of us wouldn't think twice
about seeing it included as part of a
university class but the problem you see
at least according to some of shang's
former students is that as the moorish
king lawrence olivier actually dons
blackface throughout the entire film now
of course blackface is rightfully
considered taboo especially in the year
2021 but remember shang was showing this
film specifically to focus on the
musical aspects but it wasn't long after
the screening ended that some students
took it upon themselves to file
complaints against shang
i was stunned in a school that preaches
diversity that makes sure students
understand the history of people of
color in america i was shocked shen
would show something like this in what
is supposed to be a safe place
the issue here i think though is the
assumption that university classes are
supposed to be safe spaces to begin with
the classical interpretation of
university and academia as a whole used
to be a place where you would go to have
your ideas challenged and probed and to
be introduced to other opinions some of
which yes you might even find
distasteful and frankly it does seem
like a sad state of affairs that now
students are seemingly so fragile that
they can't even watch a film that
offends them even without being asked to
engage directly with the offensive
material in question without breaking
down but in any case as is often the
story when someone offends the outraged
mob professor shang did eventually come
forth and apologize for showing the film
however after that some students still
felt that chang had not done enough to
make retribution and so one week later
he issued another apology in a classroom
i am a teacher representing the
university and i should have thought of
this more diligently and fundamentally i
apologize that this action was offensive
and has made you angry it also has made
me lose your trust shang then went as
far to actually mention specific times
in his career where he had collaborated
with people of color despite the fact
that he himself is a person of color
just to illustrate that he bears no ill
will to people of different races
at the world premiere of my opera the
silver river in south carolina in 2000 i
cast an african-american actress in the
leading role an asian female dancer and
the white baritone for the three main
characters i never thought of myself as
being discriminatory against any race
but you guessed it this groveling was
still not enough to appease these social
justice activists who had apparently
been so hurt by the showing of this film
in fact 40 different students and staff
from the university banded together to
write a formal note addressing the
department asking for shank to be
removed from his position professor
sheng responded to the events by
crafting an inflammatory apology letter
to the department students in which he
chose to defend himself by listing all
of the bipark individuals who he has
helped or befriended throughout his
career the letter implies that it is
thanks to him that many of them have
achieved success in their careers and so
for the moment at least shang has in
fact stepped down from his teaching role
and as frustrating as the story is the
sad truth is that this is far from the
first time that students have been
bullying their professors for failing to
be woken up for their standards for
example recently a ucla professor came
under fire for refusing to grade black
students more leniently than white
students in the wake of george floyd's
death and just last month dr peter
pagosian of portland state university
publicly resigned criticizing his former
university's failure to accept any ideas
that go against social justice
passionate students may be a good thing
but at a certain point universities are
going to need to enforce the fact that
students ultimately are there to learn
not to teach themselves and certainly
not to bully